بعد كل هذه السنوات ، حسنًا ،
أروع ما في العمل ، ليوسل ، صنع للتو
منجل من الألومنيوم إبراهيم القرآن عمر
فاتي ، على الأقل أنت لا
أقترح عليك دلما ، آسف كونور
سيحفل في يام ولا أعلم
كم أكثر من ذلك  أنا هذا وكل ما
تفعله للصيد هو القليل من المرح
جيدًا أم الإفطار ،
نعم واجب أعمال الجمال اللطيفة من الله أباد
واحد يشتري محليًا Adi Senna wat في نورفولك
أفوكادو روسيا أصدرت مهراجا باكن
فقط أنا آسف إذا لم تفعل ذلك
في كثير من الأحوال الآن رجل جميل كيف
يمكن للآلات البشرية التي كان لديه أي
طاهٍ والطلاق حقًا ضرب
قهوة J Calvin العامة بدون صوت
والبرتقال 59 والأهم من ذلك الاكتشاف الذي قام
به د.  يمكن أن توفر قهوة J Calvin
طريقة جديدة للجراحة وعلاج
الأمراض